just in the green room of food loves
tech how are you there's a lot of people
in loveless marriages it's an epidemic
there's you what are you thank you hey
how are you hey you feeling good
thank you so much 3d pizza huh d-roc
awesome thank you so much one thing that
I think is very fascinating is that I've
never been to a green room that's green
every day
sorry I'm shaking how are you
I think we gotta trade some wine story
eyes dude I'm so pumped by a bless you I
love it smells phenomenal you never know
when you smell some bacon
how are you Gary I mentioned during
inspiration thank you my friend
appreciate everything you do thank you
so much before you there was no one that
in the business here that showed himself
this way yeah opened himself yeah it was
an inspiration to people give that much
vision mark juban could be like the only
guy you could think of but he never
opened himself up the way you do thank
you myself I think you're a visionary
thanks for being here thank you say
hello no I know that I was gonna ask for
more like how does it feel to be so
attractive and so capable at what you
guys do
it's curious how humans like that
actually felt I thought you woke up same
mentality every morning like I do yeah
kind of that my family's gonna die and
then I'm grateful I do I don't know how
you roll
thank you yes
that's how I like it I think technology
exposes who we actually are right now
one of the favorite things of so many of
you is when you go out and you see a
couple sitting there and they're both on
the phone the whole time you love to
judge don't you right you love to say
hey look look how sad that is for me
technology has done that couple of great
service because 20 years ago that same
couple sat at that dinner table and
didn't say a goddamn word to each other
and now they actually have technology to
escape into a world and I actually look
at couples that sit there and look at
the phone the whole time as a major
positive not a negative thank you and
you know why he said that's a good one
because this man through his career saw
unbelievable amounts of couples just
sitting there not saying oh very well
cuz he loved her there's a lot of people
in loveless marriages it's an epidemic I
think the big trend right now is fast
casual premium fast casual I'm actually
completely fascinated that when the
market goes completely one way that
actually all the opportunities the other
as we all went social-media open with
Facebook and Twitter the opportunity
actually ended up being snapchat of
disappearing and over here so it's
actually happening here I'm actually
really fast day I'd love to get your
opinion on this
this is bubbling up in my head as
everything's going fast casual and the
greatest chefs of the world are trying
to produce you know a different very
casual low-priced food alternatives I
actually think super premium and quite
super fancy is it open space again
because it's just the momentum game so
for me when I see a market going one way
it starts making me understand that
there's an opportunity in the other
direction
what old what was old becomes new all
the time so weirdly I think that there's
a pent-up demand potentially for super
fancy experiences in big cities like New
York and San Francisco in LA so that's
running through my mind
you so much something yeah
nice to meet you
yes
a lot of point
thank you thank you so much nice to meet
you too
good really well
real person cut it with nicks then we go
love these kind of events Manor
co-produced this with edible magazine
New York City and and really just
excited Jose Abreu one of the great
culinary monsters chefs and in the in
the world she'll be a fun fireside chat
just a good day Friday last couple
Fridays I've been half dying them and
going out to out with family and
spending time so nice grinder today
which I feel good about did a one-hour
Operations meeting with James Orsini
chief integration officer it was
productive
I really think quick decision-making and
then reacting to the reality is quite
important you know lately a lot of my
executives are talking about the speed
of my decisions mainly cuz I'm not
crippled and I have experience but most
importantly making decisions is the win
way too many people watching this right
now are crippled to make the call adjust
their calls a really good session with
Arianna I think it was really glad that
I was able to clarify kind of you know
it's what you do when you're awake not
not while you you know how much sleep
you get kind of things that was fun fun
to get Emily who I doors been with the
company a long time to get that selfie
with we're net picture of Arianna that's
a lot of fun do you want to thank me
first my first like don't understand how
this just happened
like literally my some how much I want
to eat her and Gary's like hey they're
gonna commute link with me and we'll be
like all take a picture and I was like
because now it won't please be cool like
please don't forget they're all late
misses it yeah I'm like tits and tears
of the client connects on the picture
yeah I was like yep cassia meeting
Ariana this is against me
she's mean she's in with Arianna okay
sure thank you I'll make sure that yeah
I'm sure not spying too much just a good
great great day a lot of meetings a lot
of operations stuff today staffing new
client which have you got any but you
know timestamp it and feel like being
three hours something a lot of stuff we
can't show you like real client work
like it's funny I talk about like GCO
Bainer you know obviously there's like
stuff we can't show you because NZ as a
client stuff of that nature and I
apologize not being able to show every
aspect just not fully in control of
everything but lots of hours being put
into operation staffing hey my name is
Ross I've been a veiner on the account
strategy side for about four months now
I just had a great chat with Gary just
about goals and dreams and visions and
it's just amazing how you know we get
that access with him and and get to sit
down and kind of pick his brain for a
few minutes if you're good enough you'll
win that's what it is and so like on the
extreme and thus I should have extreme
results but like not everybody like
should have what I have like it's like
super okay that make 450 a year
[ __ ] have the greatest life of all
time it just you have to make choices
like it's just talent and hard work and
I still feel like I'm figuring out for
me like how far I want to push that yes
and it's good by the way it's gonna
change at 22 and 27 and 29 and 31
important yeah you're gonna fall in love
and the method of it did you know like
something bad will happen in your life
and [ __ ] okay something bad happened to
me tomorrow
[ __ ] about anything I don't buy the Jets
I don't want my I want my mom to get
better do you understand so yeah don't
get crippled you've tons it's up dude
I'm 18 [ __ ] years older than you yeah
you know you know for 18 years ago like
can you wrap your head around that and I
mean listen I know I look old to you but
like I'm not battle you know what I mean
like it doesn't feel that's crazy
do you know what I mean our culture
though it's like it's like we all feel
that kind of like that's what you get
when you push it's really [ __ ] pushing
it as if it's been patient and if you
push from those two extremes you [ __ ]
make [ __ ] that's that's what I've
learned so much more recently is I think
I've been on one extreme
everybody's on one extreme or the other
yeah that's why the people that push
from both extremes win yeah
that's why there's so few people that
win because much more fun to pull from
one side or the other yeah it's easy to
talk about it you can [ __ ] talk about
it I'm a good talker me too me too
but you're backing it up yeah but you've
taught you know what you can't even be
judged yet I didn't even think about
judging myself at 22 you have time talk
to me in four years when you'll still be
a [ __ ] kid yeah good luck to keep
working I get a real kind of 360 full
day I just love the action of like going
to these meetings architecting just
architecting at scale so much fun and
just you know enjoy the marathon of this
song to me you know I don't know if this
becomes a nondescript episode or becomes
one that gets a theme I know you are
always challenged by that stuff on big
shout-out to you in the last couple that
you've edited
that's right Stefan's out over the last
two maybe the three you know and so um
what I think I like about today is it's
just a good old-fashioned way of running
businesses doing media opportunities
doing event marketing interacting with
my team Jesus this is from you your
reaction was terrible
yeah oh my face dude that was a very
nice thing
I'm the best yeah
what CEO gets like love letters all day
long you guys never wrote me a love
letter not one of the four of you this
is something this is something you guys
should look deep inside yourselves
everybody out what a lot just good good
love the action addicted to the action
the action is my oxygen like I wouldn't
trade it for the world
yep hi guys I've read a goodbye good
night all right
signing off headed to uh spent some time
with the fan
and get some sleep like all of these
shed Times Square baby